it's happened to you you're shopping for
shoes you see some click on them but
decide not now not before payday not
when you're trying to be better with
money
not today Satan so you click over to
Facebook trying to run away from said
shoes and there they are haunting you
how does Facebook know you so well it's
not in your head Facebook ads targeting
and this info isn't hidden if you visit
the how ads work on Facebook page in
Facebook's Help Center you see there are
four categories where Facebook gets info
on you for advertising number one
information you share on Facebook thank
you comment on pages and posts you like
and any ads you click on on Facebook yep
that makes sense number two other
information about you from your Facebook
account
you know this includes stuff in the
About section okay that makes sense
number three information advertisers and
our marketing partners share with us
what does that mean well Facebook
advertisers share their info about you
with Facebook and in turn Facebook helps
them improve their ad audience visit the
your advert preferences page to see who
Facebook thinks you are and what they're
sharing with marketers wait one of my
interests is blanket and then lastly the
fourth category is your activity on
websites and apps off of Facebook simple
enough just gathering info on mostly
everything you click on and be be moving
on but seriously pages that have like or
share buttons notify Facebook when users
load the page and code called Facebook
pixel can be used by web publishers and
Facebook alike to track site visitors
that are also Facebook users like stick
lady Sally here this feature allows both
Facebook and advertisers to track data
like when Sally views and advertisers
product and when she adds an advertisers
product to her cart also Facebook like
many companies receives information from
data collection firms that can be used
to target ads to users so they may know
you have those odd magazine
subscriptions girls and corpses you and
retailers have the option to share
loyalty card information with Facebook
as part of an ad camp
hypothetically allowing Facebook to know
what people purchase at stores IRL we
can see how much they know if we try to
place an ad with Facebook so let's
spread the word about my new
hypothetical restaurant puddin's all
putting all the time I can choose to
place my ad to be seen by just LA living
35 year old moms that have an interest
in desserts and make good deal of money
because this is expensive pudding yeah
it can be that specific because they
could know that much info about you but
despite how personal it might feel
you're just data for them to track and
that tracking can be good for businesses
whose marketing dollars can potentially
go further super cool for my startup
puddin's but maybe you really aren't
into online interest-based advertising
all you want to do is see if your
friends saw you did that amazing hike
this morning where you snap the perfect
pick now get roped into purchases well
you can choose not to be shown certain
ads or opt out of ads from specific
advertisers completely and Facebook's
data providers third parties that gather
info have opt-out forms that users can
submit but whether you keep personalized
ads or opt out you can't stop ads
because ads are needed to help keep
Facebook free well time to get back to
puddin makin tile a lot of Mom's waiting
for me
[Music]